each year microsoft research helps
hundreds of influential speakers from
around the world including leading
scientists renowned experts in
technology book authors and leading
academics and makes videos of these
lectures freely available
my my name is Lou jahan I come from
University of of Matt of Maryland
Baltimore City I give a presentation
about about about dating aggression for
these signs you are using related
concepts here is a the well the road the
road map we have now we were first game
prob give problem Gill problem
definition which is followed by our pre
our proposed framework then we'll
discuss each main components in this
framework finally conclusion okay the
problem the problem definition you know
sharing and integrating data becomes
increasingly important for for many
scientific disciplines and for people's
pit for people state for people's daily
life and the semantic web provides a
powerful powerful integration approached
by using oncologist and unmanned and
manned mocking up data in RDF but it
still had some problems the first
problem is is that how it's a hydrogen
ed of the cement available on Colleges
the seminal violent parties are made by
different authors and for different
applications or domains the ontogeny the
untouched maybe ma-maybe model
differently and a lot of do i do a lot
of duplicate duplicate the concept may
exist how to make this like this like
this large amount of heterogeneous on
Taj interoperable still remains a
problem and we still have difficulty in
selecting ontology burkett vocabularies
I sir Sir selecting on touch appropriate
untouchable categories and then finding
the terms to a mockup data is a
difficult task for most you for most
users and moreover the ontology
development and Andy and evolution
should any relationship should be
directly driven by by users information
requirements we which however are not
easy to collect and I how to know by on
Taj makers and any users do have
difficulty in publishing and Aquarius
about 70 web data the blue parka
publishing is often abled by various the
greatest domain specific applications by
in providing input forms or a set of a
set of prepared terms to select
applications with check the way that you
that user can express and the inner
credit side and a speckle is the w3c
standard for criteria for creating a
qualitative data however besides the
problem of selecting untouchable
Cavalry's its compact syntax makes it
impossible for any you for any users to
compose sparkle queries by themselves
the problems are actually interpreting
together here we propose a framework
that intended to solve them small
taneously in this framework we remove
the boundaries between on charges and
the views the collection of our existing
untouchable Capulet terms as a single
machine representation of concepts and
in this representation the
identification of a concept is not only
a name or your eye but it can also
depend on context information certain
are such as the properties and the
relations the concept has and the Calico
the correlations with the correlations
with other concepts and in this
framework in its form of people allowed
to
use allowed to use allowed to use net
natural language vocabulary to express
the information is but but about both
both in publishing and acquired in query
data and and data stored previously can
be retrieved later despite our FLIR the
mismatching will cavalry and they and
you and you and user information needs
drive the evolution of this machine
representation on a fly the machine will
calgary is learned from and adapted to
human vocabulary but not in verse and
here is the picture out of our framework
overview in this work we have a we have
eight components firstly is the semantic
graph a 70 graph interface and we are we
which is intuitive and intuitively
intuitive you an intuitive you intuitive
user interface for people to express
their simple information needs and we
also have we also have machinery
machinery presentation of concepts MRC
amasi so we observe representation for
concept space and we also have this
application map component dynamic
dynamic i'm a solution component
property relation and concept offline
mode component and we also have a
modified cable store we which is further
instant space and query graph query our
update generation component and finally
in stock instance of line much component
now first let's look at simple
information need a simple information
need is defined as a human description
or query involving involving involving
several directly related concepts and it
can be expressed in three common
representations take
technol take on a table table table
natural language sentences under a
semantic graph we define simply
finishing it in this way is intended to
give machines a window to learn the
correlation of concepts in the world and
how they are related by relations each
simple information need can be built at
a simple point and all of them composer
the universe that can be learned by
machines and among the three common
representation the semantic graph is the
e is the easiest one to be that just by
machines because it makes the concepts
and relations in a simple information
need simply information in a simple
information it explicit two machines in
this sense a semantic graph is also the
inter inter inter me intermediate
representation for the other two lips
and patients now let's look at the
semantic graph we define semantic graph
as a high-level high-level graphic
representation on top of other of their
model and it has the complexity of value
of graph and is sufficiently intuitive
and convenient so that people can
directly you can't directly you you can
directly use it to express their simple
information needs and this is an example
semantic graph and it has the semantics
as the text why inch-long people a the
flower you know garden located at here
and it has a photo photo pictured here
the this a semantic graph it expresses
simple information in that that may be
particularly interest to biologists who
care about the invasive species in USA
ok now the calculor istics of a semantic
graph a semantic graph semantic graph
allow allow users
to directly use in English vocabulary to
label the notes and the ages so people
are not required to remember their own
costumes and the 99 if notes must be
labeled we must be labeled with concept
names like a little flower and the ages
must be labeled with with the the
property or we appropriate we are
relation names that the earlier the urn
the leaf nodes contain the property that
contain the property values I'm going to
leave note is left empty a few the video
? the semantic graph becomes a query and
are not are not are not our
knowledgeable system will try to
populate the empty nodes as the query
result now let's look at machine
facilitation of concept at MRC an NRC is
used to represent the concepts appeared
in all the simple information needs the
system has experienced animosity is a
machine representation machine with an
asian model that captures the context of
concepts and and you and you and its
context to identify concept indeed in
this way we'll be able to map concepts
in an incoming semaine de Graaff to the
concert being mr c's pursue comparing
their contacts and the and this pre on
this representation button doesn't
require doesn't require reaching
consensus on proj names we call a ematic
concept with this context information as
an encapsulated concept again ENRC MRC
every class and property still has a
corresponding item or global ID law your
items are used to mock up data in
underlying up in online ID of chubu
store however they are just
haven't to end users now the
encapsulated concept each encapsulated
concept in MRC is represented as a
couple names names clause properties
relations core concepts netnames is the
set of alternative names of the concept
and the laws I use a short description
of a concept put on properties is the
set of all properties of the concept a
property is a couple with two elements
this concept and the property name in
other words a property is always
associated with a concept put on
properties are casted according to their
semantics relations is the set of all
the relations linking this concept to
another concept a relation is a couple
ways with three elements relations our
first group by object concept and are
then a further custard according to
their semantics co concepts is the set
of all concepts that co-author which
this concept in simple information is
and this is a example for the
encapsulated concept graduates graduate
student this issue names the gloss
properties relations and the co concepts
the two relations black register and
take are clustered together because they
have the same semantics in a context of
being relations linking a concept the
concept graduates graduate student to
the concept course put putting out of
this context to relations with name
register and take they have can have
that kind of very different me very
different meanings so we cannot always
cluster them together we call a Custer
of relations as a semantic relation or
all the relations in the car
share the same you item or other sense
can be applied to two properties a
caster of relations our properties can
contain all our principal ways that
people use to express the same meaning
we presented by the caster we would like
to use this way to capture the
flexibility and variance in human
waterbury we also maintain statistics
for an encapsulated concept they include
the frequency of the concept the number
of simple information need that included
the concept the frequency of each
property the frequency of each semantic
property we r which is the sum up of
each individual e of each individual
properties properties from these
properties frequency in a costume and
the frequency of association between
this concept and one of its core
concepts the frequency of each of each
relation the frequency of each cement
relations some other statistics and the
terms in craster with the largest
frequency number is called the canonical
term in a custom and with these
frequency numbers we can compute some
some useful probabilities the
probability that a concept prob your
relation appears in the universe and the
conditional probability the bank concept
accompanies another concept the
bootstrap of MSC and we we decided to
use so many web data particularly the
idea of data indexed by Google to create
a Buddhist above MRC the good thing with
the 70 web documents he said each other
if document is actually already this mu
8270 graph because people use your items
to mock up data in rdf however will also
have to suffer from a drawback of a so
many web because a lot of duplicated
concepts now let's look at good to add
disambiguation
and the map component this component
this component design degrades and maps
concepts in incoming semantic graph to
the concepts in you know MRC in process
we have to cope with with with three
deficiencies of amasi missing properties
missing relations and duplicated concept
me me missing properties and the missing
relations can make trouble through the
simulation process so it requires our
dissemination we canceled must be robust
the duplicated concept is something that
we cannot avoid inner growth of MRC we
adopt two methodologies to cooperate
duplicated concept the first is to
cultivate a dominant concept for every
line of duplicated concepts this
requires the map component to always
pick the most the most popular one among
all kinda choices the second is to use
an offline process to merge the
duplicated concepts MRC here is the the
flow the whole distillation process can
be divided in two steps the first is are
automatically design vehicle aids and
concepts in incoming semaine de Graaff
two concepts in MRC then the system the
system the system presents the
disability Ximena graph to the user for
human inspection and adjustment a step
one automatically disambiguating and
Matt and mapping we're identifying two
kinds of probably probability map for
building models for automatically
disambiguating and mapping the first
list concept based models they exploit
the pairwise associations between
concepts they can be different ways to
mathematical associations between
concept to concepts join the probability
point-wise mutual information or
conditional probability since the
conditional probability measure only one
direction we called local observation
model it has less computational time
compared with with compare with others
the other kind model is
probably annulation pesma base model it
seeks thought it's exposed how concepts
are social associated with given
properties and relations it has higher
higher accuracy no stretch hose and
parameters but it need more
computational time so now let's look at
concept-based local observation look up
the vision model step one for each
non-leaf node we I in the incoming
cement graph we find all encapsulated
concepts sir k whose cars name matches
the vapor VIII and whose property and
relation names partially cover the
labels of the age of way I over a
designated threshold our permit Romania
seems the DS encapsulated concepts match
in the node way I from the Catholic a
look at the category I a step 24 for
every second all categories we evaluate
the following 4444 manga and where this
is the conditional probability that sage
am coming sir k the formula manages to
the maximum Association some that say k
can have with other concepts coming from
different categories in the perspective
of c ik however since the association is
measured by conditional probability the
circuit with the optimal local
observations ago may not be the most
popular one among its lines of
duplicated concepts we work around this
problem by incorporating this garbage
popular pub is popular with popularity
which leads to phone from the to wear
purple I will paralyzed is represented
by the frequency of Sir k because law
because log X because loggers because
loggers the ax grows and grows that
grows very slowly I will access la when
axis la when actually it's a lot when
axis la when X is large
the local observation score is
determinant when comparing two popular
concept on the other hand blahh gasps
blahh gasps blahh gasps blahh gasps
grows very fast when X is small the the
part of how the popularity is determined
when comparing a concept having having
high local observation score but low low
low low low public low popularity with a
public concept which is very good local
observation score the disadvantage of
this model he said we have to determine
a searcher hold on and to the permanent
w it's likely that I on w can have
different different different optimal
optimal optimal values in a different
growing stage of Emerson and step twoo
step twoo step twoo you said to you
during inspection and this is the
incoming so many graph this is La
automatically December good 8270 graph
and this is the one after after user
inspection in automatically
disambiguated semantic graph a glass is
supplying for each concept and instead
of showing the original label directly
the canonical we display the canonical
term in custer that the original label
is matched to and if a system found the
system can also suggest users to create
new concept if no property match is
found in mr see what what user can do in
the inspection is that if I found a
concert this one the glass is wrong we
can ask the system for alternatives
abroad for correct one or simply simply
simply simply simply simply create a new
one if he found the canonical term is
semantically different with the original
label he can change it back to the
original label dynamically a massive a
losing component that the annecy can
involve
from disambiguated semantic graph by
updating the frequency numbers are flick
involving concepts prob these relations
and association and it can also also
also also create new concepts property
relations that happens in incoming so
many graph the amazi can also involves
from from using inspection but comparing
the three graphs the original one the
automatic disambiguated one and the
inspected one we can get statistic
information about about black about
where the two properties and relations
should be clustered together or not so
now let's say determines determine
synonyms determine cinemas can happen
between a label you know incoming so
many graph and terms in MRC in the
disambiguation process and it can also
happen between two MRC terms in in a
classroom process the ceiling problem
will become increasingly smaller as I'm
as our monthly growth and more and more
data available in MRC because because
because because enumeration is the way
that MRC uses to capture the flexibility
and the variance of a human vocabulary
so if we already have a full grown MRC
that is all the principal vocabularies
for concept property relations have been
recorded on the custard then then we
only need that let we only need lexical
concon comparison okay but for now
determine cinema series a critical
problem the better we can resolve seems
the high recall that this immunization
and map component can become that less
effort user need to crack the automatic
disambiguate is a monograph and the
better we can do crashing on properties
and relations so we need to develop a
genetic semantic similarity function to
tell how similar two terms are and the
certain knowledge can be accepted for
this function because the mask your
commute a shin is based on matching the
whole contacts you know input incoming
semaine de Graaff to the concept in MRC
mmm the state of arts have two men
approach sponsor one and an addiction on
based approach and the others corpus
based approach our motivations to
developer a hybrid approach combining
when at Roberson and lexical similarity
conclusion we present a system that
facility facilitate dead sharing and an
in equation on a Semantic Web the system
learns his representation of concepts
from every simple information need we
presented in semantic graph and with
many represent the Duchess emigration
and it will move component
ok suppose you start at 0 level mm-hmm
you have what I understood is that you
have no
it's not not only ask questions you can
talk and how can publish to date date
date date data because for for this
overview at this level the simple
information not including queries but
also including the popular publishing
and the actual machine learning
oncologist the concept information from
from from from every simple information
needs that that given by end users they
saw an idea
yeah to me that you are doing that you
are introducing actually something we
should do to me like you're going to the
sensitive machine translation program
from you know natural language to
console a dozen times social program so
as you at this point we did some related
works but we have haven't about the
whole system is a at the time being sewn
your design